ces deux hommes filmés il ya quelques
jours sont parmi les plus recherchés par
toutes les polices chinoise à droite
yann jacky le politique conseiller de
south jiang
écarté du pouvoir parce que trop
réformiste à gauche l'étudiant plus
archaïques figure charismatique du
printemps de pékin
devenu pour les autorités un symbole de
liberté qu'il faut abattre alors que la
télévision chinoises multiplient les
appels à la délation lui réussi à fuir
la répression et rencontres à l'étranger
d'autres leaders un mouvement pour la
démocratie
notre conférence a pris les décisions
suivantes
d'abord le 12 septembre 89 à l'occasion
du centième jour de deuil nous
célébrerons dans le monde entier
une journée des martyrs chinois et aux
oies mai 2008 il s'agit de préparer un
congrès international de toutes les
forces chinoises en faveur de la
démocratie
le massacre du 4 juin est l'un des plus
terribles de l'histoire de la chine et
du monde qui a prouvé que la chine n'est
plus une république
le régime a révélé la nature despotique
en écrasant sous les tanks innombrables
personnes c'est pourquoi nous avons
décidé de faire du 4 juin la journée des
martyrs chinois
tant que le peuple n'aura pas triomphé
nous estimerons que la chine n'a plus de
fête nationale
notre tâche friture et de tout mettre en
oeuvre pour parvenir à une
démocratisation des structures
politiques et à la reconstruction d'une
nouvelle réputation fondée sur la
démocratie la liberté l'état de droit et
les droits de l'homme tuyaux
nous affirmons solennellement que nous
ne trahirons jamais les morts de pékin
et hybrides
on me dira beaucoup nous affirmons aussi
que nous ne décevrons pas les espoirs du
peuple chinois et que nous sommes
résolus à mener la lutte pour la
démocratie jusqu'au bout afin de
reconstruire la république chinois à la
tête et un cou